- Good morning Believe Nation.
Today's message is dare to fail.
Over to you, Aaron Sorkin.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wave up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
♫ I wake up every morning
- You'll meet a lot of
people who, to put it simply,
don't know what they're talking about.
In 1970, a CBS executive famously said
that there were four things
we would never, ever see
on television, a divorced
person, a Jewish person,
a person living in New York City,
and a man with a mustache.
By 1980, every show on television
was about a divorced Jew
who lives in New York City
and goes on a blind date
with Tom Selleck.
(audience laughs)
Develop your own compass and trust it.
Take risks.
Dare to fail.
Remember, the first
person through the wall
always gets hurt.
You're going to fall down,
but the world doesn't care
how many times you fall down
as long as it's one fewer
than the number of times you get back up.
- So failure is one of
the most common themes
that I come across on the
channel, and if you look at,
one side, the people who
are so afraid to fail,
and then on the second, the
people who are successful
have failed so many times.
Any successful person that you look up to,
anybody in any field,
got there by failing and
failing and failing and failing.
They've had a few successes
and way more failures.
There's a couple things around
failure that I want to address
thanks to this video.
The first is, the message of
this video is dare to fail.
I don't think you have to
be that daring to fail.
I don't think you have to go
out and do some huge, big thing
and mortgage your house
and go all in on this idea
and it has to work and
it's this massive project.
That's one option.
I think you can fail way
smaller, and I think you should.
I think as soon as you get an idea
that you want to try something,
that you owe it to
yourself to go out and try,
and fail as small as possible just to see.
Like, you want to start a YouTube channel.
Maybe that's one of your
goals or aspirations.
"I want to start a YouTube channel."
Great.
What's involved in
starting a YouTube channel?
And suddenly, you're going to say,
"Well, I need a camera and I need lighting
"and I need a microphone
and I need to do research.
"I need to learn editing skills
"or I need to hire an editor."
And you start adding
up all of these things,
and all they're doing is putting
road blocks in front of you
that prevent you from doing anything.
And instead of going big
with it, I'd say go small.
Just start.
Because so many people
will start it, will try,
like you spent all this
money buying all the gear,
doing all this stuff,
and then you do a couple,
and you don't like it.
How many things have you gone and tried
and you didn't enjoy it?
Or maybe you enjoyed it once,
but it's not going to be the thing
that you want to do for
the rest of your life
or at least the next couple years?
And that happens to so many people!
"I'm going to invest all
this money into all this gear
"to make great videos," and
then you make two, and you stop,
because it's not what you want to do,
and you're stuck with all this gear.
And so when you have this idea
of something that you
want to do, just start.
Start, with no money, with no connections,
with no resources.
Just start.
If you want to start a YouTube channel,
then you know that you
have a phone to do it,
and if you don't have a phone,
then one of your friends has a phone,
and you can borrow it from
them and make your first video.
The video quality is good enough.
The audio quality is good enough.
You can go outside and
get some decent light,
and you are good.
Make that video and start.
And if it works and you love
it and you want to eat it up,
you want to do more, great.
Make another one, and make another one,
and make another one.
You can make a business case around it?
Amazing.
Buy a proper camera.
Hire an editor.
Get lighting.
Get a microphone.
Work your way up.
Or, you do the first one, and you hate it,
and you realize you never
want to do it again.
Perfect!
Get the knowledge, because otherwise,
you have all these dreams
that just sit in your head,
"I wish I could do this.
"I wish I could do this."
All these things just sit up as wishes
that never result in any thing.
Go out and do, and fail on a small scale.
It does not have to be some
big, bold, daring dream or goal,
and even if it is, chunk it
down to what I can do today
to get started on that.
Whatever huge, big dream,
ambitious goal, you have,
amazing, I love it.
What's the first small
step that you can do
to take action towards it?
The other thing about failure
that I need to address
is people see it as some final thing,
that because you failed,
because the first thing didn't
work out, then that's it.
Failure is not a bad thing.
Failure is just feedback
on how not to do something.
Failure just means that you can get up
and do something better the next time.
If I go back on my YouTube channel
and look at my first video,
it wasn't very good, right?
It's not something that
I am insanely proud of
apart from having the courage,
I guess, to go out and do it,
but it's not something that
I watch over and over again,
and like, "Man, look
at this amazing video."
The video was not very good.
But it also wasn't a failure.
Just because it didn't get
100,000 or 1,000,000 views,
it wasn't a failure.
It was the best effort that I
could've done at that point.
And then I made another
video and another video
and another video, and 3600 videos later,
it's getting better.
And hopefully, tomorrow's
video is better than today's,
and tomorrow's Evan is more
impactful than today's,
and it's an ongoing process of growth.
The only failure is if I stopped.
The only failure is if you quit.
If there's something that
you really want to do
and you try it the first
time and you suck at it,
first, expect to suck,
'cause if it's the first
time you're doing anything,
you're not going to be
great at it from the start.
But it's only a real failure
is if you have this dream
and your first attempt doesn't
work and then you stop.
That's failure.
Otherwise, it was just an attempt.
And tomorrow you try again,
and the next day you try again,
and every day, you get a little bit better
and a little bit closer to your goal.
That's how success works.
So the question of the day today is,
I'm curious, how do you define failure?
What does it mean to you?
I'm curious.
Leave it in the comments.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to Adam Russ.
Adam, then you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word.
It really, really,
really means a lot to me,
and I hope you enjoy the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
Hey, Believe Nation.
If you want a little bit more inspiration
and motivation around failure,
here are some bonus clips
that I hope will help.
After finishing my
adventures on Dark Knight,
I decided we needed to go
into a completely different direction.
(dramatic orchestral music)
When I think of the notes for the tune,
I try to think of, "What's the solid world
"we're going to pour this tune into?"
And that's what we're doing.
Basses, can you make your
accents a bit more fierce?
We're experimenting.
(dramatic drumming)
Mighty big.
That's what you're supposed to do.
You're not supposed to stand still.
You don't really want to be observed
at your greatest failures,
and you have to invite failure
if you want to go and experiment,
and if you're to try to
do something original,
we have to have a
certain amount of privacy
to have the courage to fail.
- I listened to the
people who were successful
in selling their product.
I would learn new things
from different ones,
new approaches, and that's fair.
You must be a constant student.
A lot of people are
afraid to try anything new
because they are afraid that
they will be embarrassed
until they get good at it.
Well, one of my favorite sayings is,
"The most important thing you can do
"is to understand that
anything worth doing
"is worth doing poorly."
- What do you mean by that?
- Until you can learn to do it well.
My first few sales calls were pathetic,
but I knew it was worth
doing, so I kept after it.
My first few speeches were a disaster,
but I believed that I
could develop into that,
so I kept at until I
could do it effectively.
And all skills are exactly the same way.
No running back that sets the records
ever set a record the first
time he picked up a football.
And you go right down the line with that.
So if it's worth doing
and you believe in it,
go ahead and fail, and
the more times you fail,
the closer you're getting to success
because you should be learning
on every simple thing that you do.
- What have been the best advice
you received from your
teacher or professor?
- Ooh, I've gotten a lot of great advice
from teachers, mentors,
professors, throughout the years.
So, first of all, you got to
be open to taking some risks
and not being afraid to fail.
Failure is the key to success.
So when you get to college,
you got to raise your hand.
You have to be engaged.
Don't be the kid thinking,
"I shouldn't be here,"
and, "Maybe I'm not smart
enough, and maybe," no.
You are more than capable
of going to college,
being successful, and going on to do
whatever you want in life.
I sit here because I am you all.
There is no difference between me and you.
Working class kid, growing up
on the south side of Chicago,
growing up with doubts and fears
just like all of you all do.
I know exactly how you all are feeling,
and kids out there who were
thinking, "Maybe I'm not ready.
"Maybe I'm not good enough.
"Maybe I can't afford it."
But what teachers and
mentors have told me is that,
yes, you can, and you must.
So get in there and be bold
with your intelligence.
Raise your hand.
Get support when you need it.
And know that we all got here
because somebody helped us.